big fan of the booze I gotta cut back I
actually gotta let go from a job once
for being drunk at work
my boss called me and he goes get in
here Mark it's clear you're a high
functioning alcoholic I was like wow how
do you know I was all so high
this guy is good
one of my friends is like a beer expert
you know he's like we gotta go to a
brewery I'm like why can't we just go to
a bar he's like it's fun you can see how
it's made
I don't care how it's made
look I like porn I don't need to go to a
broken home
pornstar and broken home just the ones I
like
seems like a lot of people are quitting
the booze now it's kind of going away
all my friends are getting sober and
look that's good but some people are
better when they're drinking there's a
lot of bad sobers out there you know
we always start with the negative part
about booze what about the good like
sure you drove through a playground but
you could dance man